it's it's obviously um a very very uh
sad story here uh we've been covering
this we talked about this a little bit
yesterday so I'm going to read a letter
that the Ocean Gate Expeditions a
Twitter account sent out earlier we're
not going to read the whole thing but I
think the first line is certainly worth
repeating given it has the names of all
the people who lost their lives they
wrote We now believe that our CEO uh
stalking rush or I'm sorry Stockton rush
shazda dawood and his son
Suleiman Darwood Harris Harding and Paul
Henry
I'm sorry hey Miss Harding hey Miss
Harding that's my my mistake and uh Paul
Hardy
narglet have sadly been lost so they go
on to say that these men were explorers
who had a spirit of Adventure this is of
course a very sad story and I think that
we should try to keep reference while
discussing it a lot of people on Twitter
have been laughing at the fact that
these people died because they're
wealthy and we discussed that a little
bit on last night's show so we probably
don't have to retread that territory but
I want to open it up to you guys what do
you guys think about this what do you
guys think about the fact that the Navy
says that they heard or detected that
there was a whole implosion several days
ago and didn't say anything until now
whole whole implosion yes because when I
first heard you I thought you said whole
no no no yeah yeah I'm not sure what
that would even mean no because the hole
is
yeah yeah like a complete the whole
cracked and they found debris I think
about a third of a mile from the
wreckage of the Titanic so
The Wall Street Journal is reporting
that this uh U.S Navy technology that's
used to find an enemy submarines picked
up on what they now believe was this
implosion around the area where debris
was now found and doesn't that answer
the big question to at least one
possible non-conspiratorial answer to
the big question everyone's asking now
believe now we found the debris now we
know what that weird noise was
yeah it's true well this is something we
were talking about a little bit before
the show but there there's something
curious about the fact that they waited
to release this information until after
it was already made public that the
debris had been found and so people have
been speculating about why that's the
case I can understand why they might not
say anything because it's possible they
didn't know initially what the noise
actually was and now that the debris has
been found they can confirm that it
actually was the the uh submersible
imploding and they would probably have
some concern about dissuading Rescuers
from making attempts by telling them we
heard something that very well could
have been this craft being destroyed by
the water pressure sorry or releasing
information through the media when
really these people have families who
probably want some dignity and some
privacy while they learn possibly that
they've lost you know family members so
the Navy's claiming that they I think it
was the Navy is that who it is detected
they detected the implosion on Sunday or
shortly after they lost contact I think
maybe on Sunday and then they let a
global initiative to search and rescue
go on without telling people hey wait a
minute uh maybe because they found I so
I'm having a problem with this it's a
very emotional story there's five people
dead which is which is and then their
families and gut but I haven't seen the
debris I don't trust the news if they're
going to tell me that this thing they
know now it implore they're very Almost
sure that it imploded and they found the
wreckage like show me the evidence man I
don't buy it I don't buy this I don't
know what's going on I don't know why
this was mainly it's like you don't
believe the government yeah
what is this there's like this that I've
been divided crazy corruption scandals
about the president's son but all of a
sudden this new piece of of Pop news
takes over and and they're trying to
like shove it down my throat for five
days uh so I'm curious what do you think
happened here then if you don't believe
that this craft was actually destroyed
by the water pressure or faulty
construction uh for all I know it's
still out it's still down there and they
all died a really horrible slow death
and they don't want to put that in the
news what do you think their motivation
would be for wanting to keep that up
they want to make they want to raise
morale they want to be like they all
died painless because that's what Mike
cernovich tweeted out they all had a
painless death don't worry about it
everything's okay I remember they said
that about about uh the space shuttle
and the Challenger was a lie that it's
interesting that they would lie about
something like that what happened with
the Challenger
they had a voice recording of the last
minute because it started getting hot in
there
it didn't just break up it started
getting hot in there I'd rather not talk
about it we've had enough awful yeah you
don't have to dredge up awful news from
35 years ago it was
or whatever the hell it was sure 1984.
you know I think it was no no it was
1986 86 I was in second grade well it
was 86. Hannah clear you made this point
earlier about dignity the fact that
people had died that they lost their
loved ones and there's a media Fiasco
around this it's an interesting
exploration because we want to look at
these issues we want to know what's
happening in the world and it's good
that people were rooting for these
individuals to live you know the public
at least the the
pro-social segment of the public who
aren't just completely out of their
minds and would celebrate the death of
somebody simple because they're wealthy
we're rooting for this family but I
think I think you're on to something
with what you're saying about the fact
that there's a level of sensitivity that
needs to be considered here and it goes
beyond simply saying I acknowledge
something horrible happened here there's
an element of discretion that is
necessary yeah it reminds me of and I'm
low spring up a completely different
political point but uh when Biden
withdrew troops from Afghanistan right
we lost 13 Marines would you want those
Marines names to be released in the
media or would you want their parents to
have a chance to hear it first right
it's it's one thing we're all outraged
by tragedy or we we want to to know what
the end of this uh submarine Saga is on
the other hand real people have lost and
there has to be a slight time delay to
deliver that information now I don't
know that that's necessarily the case
here like we're saying if the Navy
picked up on some kind of sound what is
it going to do say we think we heard
something but we're not sure but maybe
like it doesn't it doesn't necessarily
serve there's no reason to believe they
didn't deliver that information to the
powers that need to be the Coast Guard
whoever's searching again I I agree with
you in here you have to remain a little
bit skeptical I think what we're seeing
a little bit now is uh the question of
why did we finally get this information
today that there is debris that we don't
think that there was an implosion and
what else is going on in the news media
that that would indicate this this
morning the news alerts I was getting
were saying you know today is the last
day that they would have oxygen so there
is a reason why this sort of yeah it's
Crescendo today we knew after today if
they weren't found things were Bleak no
matter what well I'll also say this we
know and based on what you were pointing
out earlier about the Challenger Mission
and the catastrophe there that the media
has covered up for organizations to make
the fact that people died horrible
deaths seem less tragic by claiming it
happened quickly and painlessly however
I will say one key difference is the
media might have some desire or
motivation to cover for NASA whereas I'm
not sure what the motive would be to
cover up for this small organization
that doesn't really seem to have any
connections to state or media especially
when usually they're uh I feel like the
federal government is very against
independent exploration right I mean
this was all uh Elon Musk and uh and
Richard Branson's efforts to get to
space I don't think uh the federal
government necessarily was was rooting
them on they see that as their right and
their uh exclusive uh territory again
private exploration of the sea I think
we stopped thinking about it because we
became focused on space but I'm sure
there are reasons that people want to uh
plunge the FC ocean and see what's there
it really is a world unknown to us and I
don't think necessarily these people who
have the money to do so we're wrong for
taking that risk it's just an incredibly
sad situation we I think I think it's
hard to see these videos on Tick Tock or
reels or whatever where people are kind
of laughing at it because you want to
remind yourself that like these are
people who died and someone is grieving
them and I'll mention this I think
you're correct in saying that when it
comes to exploration of parts of the
world that are currently Uncharted there
is a nobility in wanting to take that
Venture on however in the coming days or
weeks there are going to have to be some
questions asked about the particular
risks that Ocean Gate took in their
construction of this vehicle and placing
people on it and whether this was the
best constructed craft because there's
been a lot of discussion about that but
maybe now is not the time I heard there
was a waiver they signed someone on
Twitter and this is All Inked all I
don't have the Tweet but they said that
they had ridden with Ocean Gate a year
ago and to the Titanic actually and back
and they'd signed a waiver and on the
front page it was like you wave just in
case you die and they said they said
death three times on the front page
could be hyperbolic but they're pretty
much like I think maybe these these
people I actually heard so my friend um
uh legal legal mindset Andrew Esquire
YouTuber uh did a very good video that I
think he posted yep 12 hours ago today
um addressing potential legal issues
that are raised by this tragedy and
going to your point again
um because of I think what is generally
a government hostility towards
independent well any kind of
Independence and certainly big
Independence like this
um
he seemed to suggest that this is going
to provide an impetus for uh more
regulation but I I'm surprised that he
said that because the first thing he
said in his video and he's and I think
the video is great is that
there's a jurisdictional issue here this
is international waters and part of the
reason there it was there was so little
regulation is precisely because of the
lack of a regulating or and enforcing
Authority so the fact that
many countries see everyone knows that
in the world of
sailing the nautical world is if you
have any familiarity at all with the
with with cruise lines they're
notoriously unregulated they are
scandalously unregulated everyone knows
there's a problem everyone knows a
certain number of passengers disappear
are killed are robbed or thrown
overboard and no one ever there's no
accountability
the fact that we know that these things
happen doesn't make them solved they're
not solved so I don't know if this but
but there is some very one of the things
that that Andrew did point out
uh was that you can sign a waiver you
can waive all kinds of things but you
can't there's a level of negligence
of gross negligence that you cannot wave
Away by virtue of signing a waiver that
doesn't give you permission okay now I
can come into your tree house great
welcome aboard Ron I'm going to shoot
you in the head you can't do that yeah
so there will be lawyers looking very
hard at this thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time